Flight recorders are on t-minus
we have left off
Welcome back everyone to infinity and beyond so I
got a lot of requests to do a video for the light
year trailer this is a buzz lightyear movie which
is a spin-off of the toy story movies featuring
chris evans as a younger version of buzz lightyear
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs for the toy
story movies obviously there's also some marvel
easter eggs in here too because this is all disney
and easter eggs for a bunch of other movies as
well so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos but if you're not sure what's going on
here why are they making a buzz lightyear spin-off
movie is this meant to be a real version of buzz
lightyear how are they portraying this character
compared to the version that we've seen in all the
toy story movies so the director of the movie
actually clarified that the light year movie
is pixar basically making the movie that the buzz
lightyear toy was originally supposed to be based
on so in the first toy story movie when you meet
buzz lightyear for the first time he's one of
andy's toys and he's based on a movie that andy
went to see when he was a little kid so there was
a movie about a character called buzz lightyear
andy went to see it really loved the character
went and bought the toy for the character and
that's the version of buzz lightyear that we've
been following in all the toy story movies the
director of the lightyear movie and the pixar
people said what if we just made that movie that
andy saw when he was a little kid and doing it in
the tone of a star wars kind of movie like they
literally referenced star wars when they talked
about doing light year so there are some big star
wars easter eggs throughout this footage that i'll
point out as we get to it but the whole concept of
the character is that within the universe that toy
story takes place the buzz lightyear character
is meant to be from a near distant future where
humanity has got to the point where they developed
this level of technology and started to explore
space and develop faster than light engines which
is a big plot point during the trailer there's a
lot of christopher nolan interstellar energy going
on in here too with all this time dilation they do
include his catchphrase to infinity and beyond but
because this is a disney movie it's chris evans
there's this funny avengers assemble joke that
they work in one of the many marvel easter eggs
in here so the whole idea is that in avengers end
game they finally let chris evans captain america
say his catchphrase avengers assemble he said it
so many times in the comics but before end game
every time they got to a point in a movie where
he might say it they always pulled back on it
at the time they said that they just thought it
was too on the nose too cheesy and then when they
finally get to end game they're like okay we'll
finally let him say it so in the trailer when
he's about to say to infinity and beyond they just
cut it short before he finishes saying it avengers
to infinity and the music track that they use
is david bowie's space oddity major tom to
ground control very apropos the whole vibe of the
trailer makes it seem like the space rangers base
is on mars both in the early part of the trailer
when it seems like he's testing this ship out and
then later when he comes back like they're not
on earth they're on a planet near earth which is
why i say mars just because the landscape looks so
red and even though in the toy story universe the
buzz lightyear character is still meant to be a
fictional character like this is a movie that you
have to picture a young version of andy watching
in a movie theater because they want to portray
these characters in much more realistic ways than
the plastic looking toys because they are toys
the animation style they're using is way more
photo real it actually looks pretty fantastic
and it's kind of surreal seeing buzz lightyear's
hair like we've only ever seen him with the skull
cap and the helmet on i saw some people in my
feet having existential crisis just looking
at buzz lightyear's hair staring into those deep
blue eyes he still looks like the classic version
of buzz lightyear but you can see a little bit of
chris evans face in there too more marvel easter
eggs here and easter eggs for the first toy story
movie the fuel that they're using to power their
spaceship looks a little bit like the tesseract
style crystal giving off similar blue energy
but the actual crystal that they're using there
is a direct reference to the first toy story movie
so in his very first scene when they first
introduced buzz lightyear he comes in talking
about repairing his turbo boosters and asks woody
if they still use fossil fuels or if they've
discovered crystallic fusion i need to repair
my turbo boosters do people still use fossil
fuels or have you discovered crystallic fusion
well let's see we got double a's the way they're
playing this in the trailer it seems like he's
a test pilot and they've just discovered how to
harness this crystal energy and they're using him
as a test pilot to test faster than light travel
with this new type of spaceship you also kind of
get a star wars vibe from the trailer too like
some of the later scenes i'll talk about those
specific easter eggs but zurg for instance one
of the villains they introduced during toy story
2 as part of buzz lightyear's fictional backstory
literally did an empire strikes back darth vader
scene where he reveals that in the toy story
universe at least for the backstory of the toy
that he's based on he is buzz lightyear's father
surrender i have one i'll never give in you
killed my father no buzz i am your father
i don't know if they're gonna be that crazy or
on the nose with it during this actual movie
they might change that plot point but it seems
like there's some shady stuff going on later in
the trailer that i'll talk about that involves
something behind this big zurg twist you look at
buzz lightyear's dog tags he's typo positive that
just means he's a universal donor he can donate
blood to anybody even if they have a different
blood type so those are actually very valuable
people in the field especially on big missions
like this is sort of connecting things to the
wall-e movies because obviously this is a pixar
movie wall-e was a pixar movie and this is taking
place in the future wall-e also takes place in a
distant future all these robots wheeling around
here seem like the design language is similar
to the design language of the wall-e robot
it shouldn't be surprise either they're probably
easter eggs for a bunch of other pixar movies in
this as well pixar always includes a bunch of
crossover easter eggs for all their franchises
i don't think that there's any larger connection
to the events of the wall-e movie though the plot
of that movie is this post-apocalyptic future we
found out that earth started to get so polluted
that they started something called operation
cleanup because of the rising toxicity levels
everyone evacuates to these giant starliners
they were going to colonize other planets but
then eventually abandoned those plants
and stayed on the starliners to slowly
turn into giant lazy bags of flesh so i think
in the universe of the light year movie here
just the way they're playing buzz lightyear's
fictional backstory they're just a space team
trying to explore the universe and develop
faster than light travel and protect against
alien threats but a lot of you probably picked up
on the big twist in the trailer with this whole
two different timelines like there's before
the mission and then there's after the mission
and there's a big time jump that happens because
the time dilation effect there's also this funny
meta thing going on with his name being lightyear
but he's also a test pilot working on this faster
than light project so they call it hyper speed
during this movie like they have a hyper speed
reference on the whiteboard like he's going to
be traveling faster than light to reach another
part of the universe but this is just a test
you see his flight path appear here he's going
to slingshot around the sun gaining speed then fly
back through these special rings that help him to
achieve that faster than light speed and when i
reference the time dilation effect the big time
jump that happens during this trailer you see
on the upper part of this white board here they
explain a time differential because of a time
dilation effect that occurs when you travel at
speeds approaching the speed of light when that
happens time starts to pass more slowly for you
so that's why they're saying many years will
pass for the people here on the base while it
will only feel like a small amount of time has
passed for buzz lightyear inside a spaceship
so when he comes back talking about more chris
evans marvel captain america avengers easter eggs
he'll experience something similar to what captain
america experienced in the marvel movies when he
came out of the ice he'll still be exactly
the same age everyone else will be way older
that's why it seems like this faster than light
mission might just be a test like he's a test
pilot because a couple details here notice how he
doesn't have his trademark armored spacesuit when
he's in this cockpit here early in the trailer
his helmet reads zero one like he's the first test
pilot for this special new type of engine later
in the trailer when he does get the traditional
space shoot from the toy story movies his partner
here the hawthorne character seems a little bit
older than she did in the other footage and her
version of the suit now says zero one like she's
now the new number one maybe after he comes back
after a number of years have gone by there's also
a really cool visual reference to the star wars
movies and the jump to lightspeed in here too
they call it hyper speed during this movie but the
visual effect of the stars stretching past him is
right out of star wars then later in the trailer
talk about more marvel captain america avengers
easter eggs this footage all seems like it's him
from after he returns years later like years have
gone by even though it only seems like he's been
gone for a little while and he's having the same
existential crisis captain america had in the
avengers movie after he came out of the ice like
he's back on the same planet that he started on
but he's looking out at the landscape at this much
more advanced much more developed city everything
in the background just seems like it's evolved a
lot since he's been gone then there's this little
robot cat that wheels in called socks it's s-o-x
in a bunch of way more advanced robots rolling
around everywhere all over the place later in the
trailer he seems genuinely terrified by it after
it speaks to him too like talking cat what and
when he makes this karate chop pose it's because
in the toy story movies you remember the action
figure buzz lightyear has a karate chop function
talking about more star wars references and easter
eggs later in the trailer when he jumps to this
swamp planet his spaceship kind of resembles an
x-wing to begin with but the swamp planet looks
a little bit like dagobah also the sox cat
plugs its tail into buzz lightyear's ship to
interface with the computer the same way that
r2d2 plugs himself into computers then we get our
first big zurg easter eggs we knew he's gonna be
in the movie somewhere you can't do buzz lightyear
without doing zurg notice the giant robot that he
sees on the swamp plant in the background here
it's kind of foggy but you can see its head here
it's one of these robots that you see
lined up in this giant hangar bay with a z
on their chest z for zurg you also see when
the chamber opens here with the red light
shining through this is probably the big zurg
reveal like zurg will step out of this chamber
so this is where things start to get a little bit
weird in this second timeline like when he comes
back after the time jump so the star command
soldiers break into this room 27a they also
have the same type of lasers that buzz lightyear
has on his spacesuit in the toy story movies and
it seems like buzz lightyear is actually running
from them like he discovers something shady about
star command in the time jump has happened that
might be them playing into this whole notion of
zurg having this really weird relationship with
buzz lightyear like they're playing star command
at the beginning of the trailer as if they're the
heroes buzz lightyear believes that he's working
for this really righteous group doing these
really good things but then after he comes back
after this big time jump finds that something
really shady has gone on during the time jump
you could also think of that as a very hail hydra
kind of marvel twist talking about more marvel
easter eggs captain america the winter soldier
star command has been overrun with hydra agents
then they reveal the classic space ranger suit
from the toy story films there is a couple minor
differences between the original version and
this version the emblem on the chest is just a
little bit different there's no giant red button
on their arms to activate the laser weapons those
might just be integrated to the gauntlets in these
versions but it's mostly meant to look exactly the
same just a little more practical like this could
exist in the future of our real world like the
whole visual design of the movie is in service of
making it feel like it could really exist instead
of being toy versions like the toy story movies
like gimme toy story but with ray tracing overall
it actually looks like a pretty decent film chris
evans said that he had a lot of fun working on it
he's really stoked up about it but if you spotted
any big easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below
in the comments i just did a brand new hawkeye
trailer video with a bunch of new footage and
daredevil easter eggs you can click here to watch
that and click here for my brand new spider-man
no way home sinister 6 preview breakdown with
a bunch of new footage thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe to infinity and beyond